kang-cook sure I don't date anymore I'm
using a speckles messed up well I got a
lot without putting my nails little
saying I'm gonna use glitter I mean I'm
her blue purple a skater so I could use
that this is purple yeah next our next I
want to rank a guy perfectly okay I'm
princess what I'm going through a window
world what husband yeah get up yeah get
up hmm I with this one some kind okay
are you guys like it for today
I like to make hot like a little bit
it says I love mom
sigh here loves calling was dad
and nothing on the back here
[Music]
you can't gonna win ten horse now
exactly how do you hide a few ago my
turn hard
oh yeah the hose that's hard
the reason I don't like the pink helmet
foxy the most is because one of them is
my little sister and little sisters and
Big Brother's don't go well together
yeah I would not I if I could I would
grab like a rocket launcher or something
go into the princess world and blow up
all the castles oh you should've told me
yeah now me come to meet you I thought I
loved that so much I love avocado
[Music]
please Angela I'll pound them to death
Wow I remember one little boy went up to
her and said can you even skate and she
came up and told me that and was kind of
devastated and I said Bella you know you
just need to prove that you can I
weren't here to be interesting the
mountains close to be skiing as the same
amount of boys I want to be a
professional skateboarder one day I want
to go ice skating I want to go to XP
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and yeah
[Applause]
her whole life she's going to have to
prove to the boys that she can do it
you'll find like three boys are like
princesses but those three boys aren't
us three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Shankaran I cry sometimes I don't what
sometimes they get burns one time so
hunt my knees sometimes I get reverses
listen it sounds like okay
[Music]
check him out we could feel better he
did severe that I gave you the biggest
smile that was
[Music]
I mean what I'm learning is there's no
limits to what they can do like I
certain times like there's no way she
can do this and she'll do it
we're going to keep my mouth shut like
actually well I know you know I think
it's pretty cool about get their take
steer a little girl they're dropping in
bowls and stuff
I'd like to see the detail and Posse
every word and pretty soon little girls
everywhere just having fun ski for you
and I think that'd be awesome
[Music]
boy stay still try step one step ground
my skateboard
[Music]
knock knock who's there
orange orange slice banana
[Music]
you